I think the future of agriculture in
California is really at risk today Don
Cheadle was here and we were talking
about issues of satellite observations
of groundwater depletion how it's
happening in California over the last
few years California's lost something
like four trillion gallons of water per
year I'm sorry what trillion with the
tea can you tie this into climate change
absolutely I'm just trying to put myself
in the shoes of an audience member who
may be watching this and ask the
questions that they would be thinking
about the picture that emerges is is not
a pretty one we all need to really
change our relationship with water we
don't have it in the abundance that we
once did and a lot of that's because of
the depletion of non-renewable
groundwater so if we want to keep doing
all the things that we have been doing
we have to do it with a lot less water
and we have to we have to make that
adjustment I mean this is insane
I am getting to the point where I'm not
sleeping well at night it it stands to
change our food security or energy
security our human security globally I
mean this is really scary stuff exactly
these problems are not just California's
problems but really happening all over
the world as much as I thought I knew
I'm learning so much more and really
just trying to find solutions and
triangulate this from all different
angles and come up with a plan that's
comprehensive and that can be a model
for the rest of the country and
potentially the rest of the world
shows like years of living dangerously
are a tremendous vehicle for getting the
message up yet I have a message the
message of the global groundwater crisis
and we need all the help we can get